ok tu as fait beaucoup de télé mine de
rien ça fait énormément de télé c'est
quoi les missions qui t'a le plus marqué
c'est on et vous en terre inconnue
ah bah ouais ça c'est un choc dans une
vie avait bien fait [ __ ] je me suis
d'abord bien fait [ __ ] mais c'est
devenu anecdotique par rapport à la
puissance de ce que j'ai vécu là-bas
après après l'émission ça a complètement
changé les gens dans la rue ça il t'en
parle encore ouais les gens m'en parlent
beaucoup
c'est surtout que et aux tpe j'étais
dans l'himalaya
mais c'est un public qui me
connaissaient pas en plus vraiment
beaucoup j'ai l'impression que les gens
qui ont canal+ qui regardent ces 8 me
connaissent un petit peu mais mais là
c'est le public de france 2 donc j'ai ya
plein de gens qui m'ont découvert et
plein de gens qui dès le lendemain viens
de te voir dans la rue les yeux un peu
rougis d'émotion parce que vraiment ils
ont vécu un truc avec toi [ __ ] quel
con ça changer des choses dans sa vie
dans même dans ta carrière ou pas oui
non la vie différemment maintenant parce
que je suis pas été un peu rencontré toi
même jamais parti pour rencontrer
mais j ai pleuré en regardant les aura
vu des gens là bas tu as gardé mais tu
as gardé contact extraits d' eric lopez
n'ont pas vraiment plus avec raphaël et
qui je suis parti du coup avec c'est
vrai moi je suis comme vous savez je
suis pas parti avec intérêt mais mauvais
mec très direct parce qu'il y avait eu
nous aviez faire un truc genre vous
étiez pas chier mais pas du tout en fait
et tu sais ce que je veux c'est lui qui
t'a va plus à la base pour que tu fasses
l'émission oui oui donc il s'agit là mis
en scène où sa fin d'émission est ce ce
que je ce que j'ai compris c'est çà çà
çà çà a permis ça m'a permis moi de
faire lâcher prise supplémenté un seul
être vous manque et un bon souvenir
oui mais tu pourra nous dire des prénoms
de gens avec lesquels tu a sympathisé là
bas ah bah oui je n'oublierai jamais
vas-y bouge tout et roshan à deux
marques à l'antenne tu es bien revoir
des extraits de cette émission
j'aime bien au revoir des extraits des
émissions général verdict
c'est dur de se quitter
[Musique]
j'ai compris des choses essentielles
avec vous tous alors merci de nous avoir
accueillis vous oublierai jamais
et bonne chance
nous
[Musique]
techniquement cette émission mais dans
la forme ça veut dire qu'on est très
populaire pour toi c'est sain c'est un
fait combien de prises pour les hackers
gg pas du tout je vais faire comme ça
j'ai nommé j'ai toujours eu conscience
de la chance que j'avais que fred me
propose de faire cette émission mais et
c'est vrai que quand tu es là bas y tu
vises un tu oublies que tout ça c'était
une émission de télé moi j'ai vu jamais
christian petit qui n'a pas de papa se
voit l'avenir
tao vidéos tournées ou paris
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non mais tu sais qu'ils font ça ils font
retour en terre inconnue et je garde
espoir qu'on y retourne en jour et alors
moi je t'ai connu de kaïra shopping
voilà un match j'étais très fan regarder
que ça donne et sa bande de bâtards bons
soirs pourquoi c'est moi qui présente
aujourd'hui une fois n'est pas coutume
comme on dit par ici c'est parce que mon
gars abdelkrim aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qu'il va faire il va se lancer dans le
show business comme on dit pourquoi
parce qu'il sait faire plusieurs
simulations basées françois javel
africains auraient déchire pas à bientôt
aux combattants du fatah ya aussi
pattaya et ge pour un peu que tu prends
une grosse grosse gifle et est ce que tu
te rappelles tu es en effet l'émission
on sent que ça fait un show son open
très bien et tu avais pris une autre
flou j regardez claque de plus belle la
vie après cinéma
allez-y mais t'as aucune raison de faire
ça a violemment d'auxonne ça va se faire
gentiment très bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les téléspectateurs avant l'émission il
y avait un truc non c'est vraiment par
plaisir je sais pourquoi elle l'a giflée
pourquoi à cause de retour en avion
qu'est-ce qui a eu et un problème mon
retour d'avion en corse
c'est quoi cette histoire qui en a les
somptueux un retour difficile pour vous
êtes allé en corse avec ça brûle et on
retourne y avait un problème
oui il est passé de jets privés à
easyjet tu veux en parler
j'ai l'impression qu'il a des doutes ce
qu'on n'a pas ouais mais excuse moi toi
tu es devenu le nouvel ardisson on va
laisser réfléchir si vous nous raconter
cette anecdote
non mais je racontais voilà il a tout
fait pour l'en mettre plein la vue à
l'aller et puis ce fut au tour quoi
[Rires]
easyjet
ouais non chine maintenant sur d'autres
dossiers 1 alors pourquoi mais pourquoi
mais je trouve ça très beau moi c'est
bien si vous êtes très beau de montrer
qu'on peut être riches et pauvres dans
la pâte à pain charmant une grosse merde
j'ai pas de bon oui tu veux aurait fait
de tubes extraits sonores mais c'était
un truc de dispo et eon retour oui bah
j'ai besoin que tu toi tu as appelé que
des ennemis pas de pas d'amis toi c'est
doux c'est la famille et franck tu as
fait toutes les émissions
tu avais fait un non match chaud avec
moi sur canal+ oui et tu m'avais ramené
à noir regarde
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
castro
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est la nouvelle collecte moitié des
lits sous qui la servent été l'épousé
salle a donc fait offrir le dvd merci
voilà donc ces gens mais après je me
suis excusé terry poussant pas du tout
je veux te dire pourquoi on n'a jamais
diffusé l'émission je vais tenir parce
que à un moment tu fais un appel at on
appelle arthur et et c'était très
compliqué de couper parce qu'on avait
fait parler de ça pendant toute
l'émission en fait est ce que tu te
rappelles de ce qui s'était passé là oui
très bien en fait parce que franck avait
appelé arthur il y avait laissé un
message
un petit peu chaud ou pas et derrière
comme on allait parler pendant toute
l'émission et qu'on pouvait plus passer
l'appel
on a dû jeter l'émission est vrai qu'il
ya un dossier sur cette émission que je
faisais sur canal puis j'avais fait une
dizaine de numéros c'est pas de nom en
fait je me rappelle que tu m'as mis dans
une situation très embarrassante comme
ça tu arrive assez souvent mais là
c'était vraiment très problématique et
je me suis souvenu que souvent tu avais
ce jeu dès que tu t'ennuies devenait on
appelle des gens et donc je me rappelle
qu' on devait appeler des gens on était
ensemble avec malik et malik avait eu la
présence d'esprit quand il a vu que tu
allais démarrer ce jeu devenait on
appelle des gens pour les faire chier de
bloquer des numéros talent et vouloir
qu'on appelle tu vois et ce jour là à la
night
j'ai pas pensé à tous les bloquer et on
a va plaire turc tav envoyé je crois un
message arthur totalement contre mon gré
exactement coach et il t'avait rappelait
d'ailleurs dans l'émission en direct et
on devait couper la séquence pour ça
qu'on n'a jamais passé et c'est dans une
période où tu n'es pas en gang au grand
amour avec arthur ouais ouais aider
c'est souvent
[Rires]
la vie d'adulte et l'émission rock dont
tpm ps que tu te rappelles quand je
t'avais piégée je t'avais piger dans tpm
pays c'est arrivé plusieurs fois
ouais mais là c'était pendant la pub je
t'avais dit que je devais ramener un pas
dans quelle bataille fait c'était pas du
tout un pataquès je me rappelle très
bien le rhône et de jouer le jeu quand
même regarder une petite couilles donc
on a pris un comédien en fait la musique
qui va se passer
tu fais surtout si je te dis ludovic way
est ce que ça t'évoque quelque chose
c'est possible tu partagé beaucoup de
choses avec lui il est mort de rire
regarde ludovic
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors tant que je n'ai pas vu non je te
suis face au ca non je ne suis pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]